we're going to continue our discussion
on the law of supply and in particular
in this video we're going to get a
little bit deeper to make sure we
understand the difference between a
change in supply and i'm just using the
greek letter delta here for shorthand
for change in supply
versus a change in
quantity
supplied and just as a bit of review
we've talked about in other videos
supply is referring to the entire supply
curve and this curve right over here has
a typical shape of a supply curve
following the law of supply at low
prices suppliers would provide low
quantities and at higher prices
suppliers would provide higher
quantities so a change in supply would
be a shift in this entire curve so for
example if you were to go from this
curve let's call this s1 here and we
were to have a shift to the right
this right over here would be a change
in supply
so this we'd call this s2
and we would have this shift you could
view this to the right or to the right
and down
so this would be our change in supply
likewise you could have a change in
supply the other way
where you go to the left and up
depending on how you want to view it and
so this would be we could call that
supply curve 3. these would all
represent shifts in supply or changes in
supply when we talk about quantity
supplied we're talking about shifts
along one of these curves so for example
at some price so let's say we have this
price p1 right over here associated with
that price we would have some quantity
supplied
we have some quantity supplied let's
call that quantity supplied one
and then let's say for some reason we
have a shift in price with the market
forces not changing from a supplier's
point of view and so let's say we go to
price two
let's say we go to price two we would
shift along that same curve the curve
itself wouldn't have shifted and so then
you have quantity supplied too so change
in supply is a shift of the curve to the
left and up or to the right and down
versus a change in quantity supplied is
moving along the curve and the
associated quantities now with that out
of the way let's do some tangible
examples and think about what it results
in a change in supply or change in
quantity supplied
so let's say
that the government decides that gas
prices are too high
and so they institute a price cap and
we're going to talk much more about
price caps in future videos but a price
cap might just say and let's say that
price cap is below the current price so
let's say the current price is at p2 and
that the price cap the price cap is at
p3 so the government says no one is
allowed to charge more than p3 for
gasoline what would that result in would
that result in a change in supply or a
change in the quantity supplied
well this is a classic case of a shift
along a supply curve the price was there
before now it shifts here and so now
we're going to have a different quantity
supplied so this would be quantity
supplied three so this is a change in
quantity
quantity supplied
and in this case the change in quantity
supplied the quantity supplied would
go down assuming that the price cap is
below what the price was before the
price cap
now let's give another scenario let's
say
that the price of refining gas goes up
price
of
refining
goes up what would that do would that be
a change in supply or a change in
quantity supplied and pause this video
to think about it
well this is something that would
increase the cost of
of producing gasoline which is refined
from oil across the board regardless of
what price we're at so this would be a
general shift this would be a change in
supply and the entire supply curve to
think about which way it would shift
think about it from a
a supplier's point of view at a given
quantity so let's say we're at this
quantity right over here at a given
quantity they would now want to charge a
higher price and so you would have and
this it doesn't apply just to that
quantity could be this point of the
curve this point of the curve this point
of the curve they'd want to charge a
higher price to make up for the fact
that refining is now more expensive and
so this would be a shift you could view
it to up or shift upward and to the left
you could also view it the other way at
a given at a given price suppliers would
want to provide less quantity because
they need to make up the fact that
they're paying more for that for
refining that gasoline and so that you
could do that as a shift to the left or
shift of up and to the left
and so that would be
in that direction we're kind of shifting
like that and then of course we could
talk about a scenario that goes the
other way
let's say that the property tax
property
in the entire market property tax
on
gas stations
goes
down
so in theory if the property tax goes
down the cost of running a gas station
goes down and this is for everyone in
the market not just one player in the
market
and so
they might for given price be able to
supply more of a quantity or for a given
quantity be able to lower the price
either way you could imagine shifting
from s1 to something that looks like s2
going down and to the right so once
again this would be a change in supply
because you would have a shift
regardless of what price and quantity
supplied you are actually at